Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Some time ago, smartphone cameras were trying
to outpace each other by adding more and more
megapixels to their specification sheet.
The difference between a half megapixel image
and a 4 megapixel image was night and day.
However, nowadays, we have entered into diminishing
returns as most newer mobile cameras support
8 or more megapixels.
At this point, a further resolution increase
doesn't lead to significantly more convincing
photos - and here is where the processing
software takes the spotlight.
This paper is about an AI-based technique
that takes a poor quality photo and automatically
enhances it.
Here, you can already see what a difference
software can make to these photos.
Many of these photos were taken with an 8-year-old
mobile camera and were enhanced by the AI.
This is insanity.
Now, before anyone thinks that by enhancement,
I am referring to the classic workflow of
adjusting white balance, color levels and
hues.
No, no, no.
By enhancement, I mean the big, heavy hitters
like recreating lost details via super resolution
and image inpainting, image deblurring, denoising,
and recovering colors that were not even recorded
by the camera.
The idea is the following: first, we shoot
a lot of photos from the same viewpoint with
a bunch of cameras, ranging from a relatively
dated iPhone 3GS, other mid-tier mobile cameras,
and a state of the art DSLR camera.
Then, we hand over this huge bunch of data
to a neural network that learns the typical
features that are preserved by the better
cameras and lost by the worse ones.
The network does the same with relating the
noise patterns and color profiles to each
other.
And then, we use this network to recover these
lost features and pump up the quality of our
lower tier camera to be as close as possible
to a much more expensive model.
Super smart idea, loving it.
And you know what is even more brilliant?
The validation of this work can take place
in a scientific manner, because we don't need
to take a group of photographers who will
twirl their moustaches and judge these photos.
Though, I'll note that this was also done
for good measure.
But, since we have the photos from the high-quality
DSLR camera, we can take the bad photos, enhance
them with the AI, and compare this output
to the real DSLR's output.
Absolutely brilliant.
The source code and pre-trained networks and
an online demo is also available.
So, let the experiments begin, and make sure
to leave a comment with your findings!
What do you think about the outputs shown
in the website?
Did you try your own photo?
Let me know in the comments section.
A high-quality validation section, lots of
results, candid discussion of the limitations
in the paper, published source code, pretrained
networks and online demos that everyone can
try free of charge.
Scientists at ETH Zürich maxed this paper
out.
This is as good as it gets.
If you have enjoyed this episode and would
like to help us make better videos in the
future, please consider supporting us on Patreon
by clicking the letter P at the end screen
of this video in a moment, or just have a
look at the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!